vous vous souvenez d'Yves le supporter
de Calais qui avait perdu sa femme on
l'a perdu
[Applaudissements]
on la retrouvait
[Musique]
les supporters même les plus étourdis
revoir avec émotion les images de cette
qualification pour la finale vous avez
l'air fatigué un peu hein
une nuit d'enfer et lui d'en faire cette
dérive et puis j'ai perdu ma femme on
l'a perdu
j'étais parti c'était contre Bordeaux et
puis on était dans l'ambiance et tout
puis et puis en sortant du mal on avait
gagné tout se
et j'étais parti avec ma femme et j'ai
perdu ma femme le beau c'est-à-dire que
je l'ai perdu c'est de ma faute aussi
parce que j'ai il y avait tellement de
bus sur
les parkings on avait un numéro de
citron dans l'ambiance alors du coup
j'ai un peu ça je monte à Meuse mais bon
manque de poule
si ça aurait été à Saint-Omer et puis
tout le monde descend
coller ah bah dis donc
Saint-Omer je me suis collégien j'ai
comment que je peux voir partir
quel souvenir vous garderez du match
d'hier soir la deuxième Coupe du monde
et notre entraîneur c'est aimer Jacquier
on se voit
non tous au Stade de France tous
ensemble et tous ensemble on y va tous
et si ma femme en organe
avec moi
[Rires]
[Musique]
on était en fait le 12 avril à quelle
heure
jusqu'au bout parce que des mecs qui ont
entendu
trois heures du matin les principaux
acteurs de la soirée investissent la
ville ladislasano et ses hommes sont
accueillis en héros
à l'ambiance formidable dans le bus
les commandes
je vous dis pas c'était vraiment
formidable chanter même le chauffeur
aussi
il avait tellement l'habitude et puis
l'hommage partait travailler mais
j'avais
pas le temps moi a pas tant dit non il
veut
je te donne repos aujourd'hui
et Gino
à 23 ans demi-finale que les Bordeaux 3
et la finale de la Coupe de France au
Stade de France Calais Nantes
malheureusement non quelle est n'a pas
gagné quel est le brandira pas la Coupe
de France et pourtant
les rues de la ville sont encore noires
de monde on chante on danse
la fête malgré la défaite je sais pas à
Nantes ce qui se passe de quoi ici ça
aurait été vraiment la folie parce que
c'est la première fois et pour attendre
qu'alezia aucun budget rien du tout ils
arrivent en finale c'est magnifique on
va
au café des Canaries mon nom
tout a commencé
on est parti
avant j'étais à droite
c'était vraiment la campagne j'ai la
campagne de la campagne un grand terrain
de 1400 mètres carrés
comme malheureusement ma femme avait
décédée je me suis retrouvé tout seul
alors j'ai voulu me rapprocher un petit
peu des enfants faire caler quoi
et puis voir un peu plus de monde parce
que là moi j'ai pas de voisins j'avais
rien du tout c'était vraiment le désir
du désert quoi alors vers 4 ans je serai
prête
[Musique]
Coupe de France récolter
ça a changé
[Musique]
beaucoup de copains
les anciens qui sont partis
malheureusement
ça joue beaucoup
nostalgie
ça sera à faire de leur fils
[Musique]